il fait beau et chaud et les québécois
profitent des piscines et des plans
d'eau après des mois de confinement
mais l'excès de confiance peut donner
une tournure dramatique à ces jeux au
cours du dernier mois l'hôpital du
sacré-coeur à montréal a accueilli cinq
cas de fractures à la colonne cervicale
suite à des plongeons cette première
dont 3 dans les 10 derniers jours
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit durant
l'été mais autant de corps dans une
période si rapprochées c'est quelque
chose d'habituel toutes les victimes
sont aujourd'hui tétraplégique
quand il parle des ennemis étaient pas
game le plonger dans ce n'était pas
grave me faire un backflip les jeunes
hommes ont tendance à avoir plusieurs
recueils à faire plus de folie sous la
pression à 15 ans c'est exactement ce
sentiment d'invincibilité qui a poussé
solesmes demetri a plongé dans sa
piscine hors terre au mois d'août 1998
c'est pas une grosse expérience que
j'avais à ce moment le d'alcool je sonne
bien me fait tourner la tête puis m'a
fait plonger dans l'eau dus à l'alcool
j'imagine que c'est pas un plongeon que
jeter dessus de faire le une acrobatie
qui lui a coûté l'usagé de ses jambes
on peut pas croire qu'enfin soit plus
c'est possible et
c'est beaucoup trop difficile c'est
beaucoup trop gros comme nouvelle et au
fil du temps c'est sûr que j'ai j'ai
compris que ça allait rester comme ça
mais même encore aujourd'hui ça fait 21
ans que j'y crois encore quatre fois sur
cinq ces accidents concernent des hommes
la plupart âgés de 18 à 44 ans selon la
société de sauvetage du québec souvent
l'abus d'alcool est un facteur aggravant
et la pandémie peut expliquer en partie
certains comportements des gens ont été
confinés donc maintenant ils ressortent
ils ont l'impression qu'il recommence à
vivre un petit peu donc c'est possible
qu'ils soient un peu plus enjoué autour
d'une piscine ou dans des bassins d'eau
qui sont peu profonds
c'est certain que parfois pas toujours
mais parfois l'alcool joue un rôle là
dedans aussi
la société de sauvetage rappelle que
pour un plongeon sécuritaire la
profondeur de l'eau doit être d'au moins
2 75 mètres sur une distance de 6 m ici
simon couture radio canada montréal